now here's a funny thing the whole time
they were doing this I was saying it's a
semantic game they'll say we we don't
Shadow ban anybody it's called
visibility filtering it's totally
different they would say we did not
Shadow ban anyone for being conservative
we Shadow banned them for misgendering
someone of course liberals and
conservatives have you know opposing
views on what misgendering is so of
course they're literally doing it based
on the political ideology or political
values of the individual yeah I didn't
punch you in the face I just threw my
fist at your your uh you know face you
know so that's technically not the same
thing right guys it's absolutely
incredulous it's absolutely like insane
Congress says uh you know Miss God a is
there a door on the front of Twitter's
building no there isn't there's no door
no there's not what do you mean there's
not well what we have is a large pane of
Glass on hinges with a handle that when
you pull it actually moves on the hinge
creating an opening for which you can
move through but it's not a door